so if I were to ask you if I were to
tell you that negative 3 minus blank is
equal to negative 4. can you pause this
video and figure out what this blank is
all right now let's do this together and
I'm going to do this by drawing out a
number line because that's what my head
tries to do with things like this let me
draw a straighter line than that all
right that's a pretty good number line
let's see I'm going to be dealing with
negative 3 and I'm going to subtract
something of it to get to negative 4. so
let me focus on the negative end here so
let's say this is zero that could be
positive one then I have negative 1
negative 2 negative 3 negative 4
negative five let's go negative six
that's the other end of it so this is
negative one negative two negative three
negative 4 and negative 5. so let's
start at negative three so negative 3 is
that point on the number line and I want
to end up at negative four that is that
point on the number line so to go from
negative three to negative four I have
to go one step in the leftward direction
so one step in the leftward direction
you could either view that as
subtracting one or you could view that
as adding a negative one now we have
we're already subtracting here so we the
simplest thing to do just say okay this
is the same thing as subtracting one and
we're done negative three minus one is
indeed equal to negative four
let's do another example
let's say we had negative one
is equal to negative seven minus what
pause the video and try to work through
that and try to do a number line I
always find that useful
all right let's work through this
together again so let's let me draw a
number line here
let's see I have a negative one I have a
negative I have a negative seven so I'm
going to deal with the negative end of
things so let me make this zero I'll
make that positive one negative one
negative two negative three negative
four negative 5 negative six negative
seven let me write this this is negative
seven right over here negative eight
negative nine negative ten I think
that's probably enough so let's see
we're saying negative one is equal to
negative seven minus something so
essentially we're starting at negative
seven here
we're starting at negative seven
and we're subtracting something from
that to end up over here at negative one
this is negative one right over there so
let's just think about what the arrow
needs to do to get from negative seven
to negative one well to do that you're
going to have to go it looks like six
units to the right one two three four
five six we go six units to the right
now there's two ways to describe going
six units to the right you could say
that is just plus six or you could view
that that's the same thing as minus
negative six and we've seen that
subtracting a number is the same thing
as adding its inverse
and since we already have a a negative
sign here A minus sign here we might as
well say well this is the same thing as
subtracting a negative 6. uh negative
six I'll put in parentheses to make it a
little bit cleaner and we're done
let's do another example another example
here
so let's say
we I'll make it give us ours gives
ourselves give ourselves a clean slate
let's say we wanted to figure out so I
have blank minus negative 5 is equal to
13. how would you tackle that
well let me just draw my number line
again I have my whole real estate to use
this time so let me just go all the way
there let's see I'm dealing with
something it's going to be roughly five
away it feels like from 13. so let me
just uh make my number line I'm just
going to say this is zero I have to get
to 13. so actually let me give myself a
little bit more space so this is 0 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18.
I think that is sufficient
so we don't know where we're starting we
know we want to end up at 13. so 13 let
me let me put that on our on our number
line here so it's one two three four
five six seven eight nine ten eleven
twelve thirteen so thirteen is right
over here and now how did we get to 13
well we are subtracting a negative 5.
now as I just mentioned subtracting a
number is the same thing as adding the
inverse of the number so this is the
same thing as adding
positive 5 is another way of thinking
about that so or another way of
depicting either of these subtracting
negative 5 or adding positive 5 would
essentially be you're starting someplace
and you're going five units to the right
so you started someplace and you're
going five units to the right to end up
at 13. so that means you started five
units to the left one two three four
five you started right over here you go
five units to the right and you ended up
at 13. well this right over here five
units to the left of 13 this is going to
be eight
and it is indeed the case that eight
minus negative five is equal to 13.
now there's other ways that you might be
able to think about this if something
minus negative 5 is equal to 13 then
another way you could think about it if
I were to tell you that 3 minus 2 is
equal to 1 you could also say that an
equivalent statement is that 3 is equal
to 1 plus 2. you could turn that
subtraction equation into an addition
equation so over here if I say this
minus this is equal to that then that
means that 13
Plus
negative 5
must be equal to blank our mystery
number and if I add 13 and negative 5
you might recognize that as being equal
to eight so either way there's a lot of
ways that you could approach this but
they all get either kind of the same
conceptual place